sentenciado a 25 años de cárcel un
tribunal de Moscú declaró culpable a
Vladimir karamuza por el crimen de
traición a la patria y denigrar a las
fuerzas armadas es la pena máxima que
podía recibir el periodista y líder
político de 41 años es un opositor de
largo plazo del kremlin durante años ha
expresado su descontento con el gobierno
de Vladimir Putin y se ha solidarizado
con la lucha de otros opositores como el
opositor asesinado Boris nexto
pudieron matar a un hombre pero no
pueden matar su memoria ahora han pasado
siete años y todos los años viene gente
aquí todos los días hay flores frescas
todos los días se encienden velas a
pesar de todos los intentos de las
autoridades de asegurarse de que
boristen soft se ha olvidado sigue
siendo recordado
después de la invasión de Ucrania por
parte de Rusia Vladimir karamuza criticó
la intervención rusa lo que provocó su
arresto en 2022 desde que fue imputado
varios miembros de la comunidad
internacional han abogado por la
liberación de karamurra varios países
denunciaron la condena como Reino Unido
que ha descrito la situación como una
sentencia por motivos políticos
pedimos la liberación de los detenidos
en Rusia por motivos políticos como
alexey navalni y que se libere a los
encarcelados por su oposición a la
guerra ilegal de Rusia en Ucrania como
Vladimir kara mursa
garamuza enfrenta la sentencia más dura
por el delito de traición a la patria
desde que inició el conflicto en